I do believe that people have kind of
what I call a religious core I don't
know what your personal religious
beliefs are but I know how much Jordan
Peterson has influenced you and
obviously me as well and that is one of
the things he shifted me on this idea
that there has to be something above you
that that is sort of real and empirical
otherwise you'll always be looking for
it in man and that that has sort of led
to where we're at now with so many of
these movements because they think they
can fix man yeah and perhaps man can't
be fixed yeah well I think in terms of
my own views I'm a Christian I'm very
I'm very open about that always have
been raised in a Christian family whole
family's Christian and one thing I'm
noticing which I think is interesting is
a lot of people who are atheist or
agnostic I'm finding who have been
embroiled in some of this to a degree
not everybody but I think that a lot of
people are one some of them are actually
starting to believe in God and become
more religious but even those who are
not I think are starting to better
understand some of the benefits of
religion and sort of seeing what can
take place in its absence because I do
believe I don't know how well this has
been studied I do believe that people
have kind of what I call a religious
core so everybody it's natural as an
adult as you get older to contemplate
the meaning of life or wonder what the
ultimate power is wonder why wonder how
we all got here why we all are here want
to know what the ideal is where does
morality come from all these ideas
people want to have community people
want to be a part of something and
that's to me that's just inherent in
human nature so for some people who are
religious the religion solves and
answers mm-hmm a lot of a lot of those
things whereas I think for somebody who
is not something else normally or often
I mean I may not say it say normally but
often will fill that gap yeah
well that's why that's why Pete Bogosian
he talks about this post-modernism as a
secular religion which makes so much
sense and this is he's an atheist I mean
he wrote a book called a manual for
craziness so that this is not something
that he wants to see where we're a
theism maybe has a an end of the road
that is in exactly what they want it to
be yeah but he describes that as a
second religion and I think a lot of
atheists cuz I get this I mean I get a
lot of fan mail about this where
atheists are like Peterson often was the
guy that kind of showed them that the
road kind of ends of secularism if it's
unhinged
from something real before that that
you're going to end up in this in this
you know competing intersectional mess
well I don't think it's an accident that
I mean even in 20th century I don't
think it's an accident that the big
scary totalitarian fascist regimes made
a significant effort to root religion
out of people and out of society before
they implemented their own structures
and ideologies because religion if
you've got something that's already in
that hole then I do personally believe
it of course religion can be used for it
can be used for malice it can be misused
for evil and whatever but I think in its
I think a lot of people have this sort
of utopian idea that if you could root
that out then everyone would kind of get
along mm-hmm stop fighting over what and
I truly don't believe that I think on an
individual basis fine you know if
someone if someone can be moral and
rational and have their own thoughts and
ideas and whatever that it's complete in
absence of any belief in God or religion
or whatever then absolutely totally fine
when you take hundreds of millions of
people or billions of people and you
root that out I this might be the
pessimist in me but I don't believe that
I don't I don't think that space won't
stay empty
yeah something else better or worse will
come in there and fill that hole it
could be this
weird intersectional religion it could
be some kind of very heavy political
ideology or belief which basically turns
some sort of leader into a God mm-hmm
drugs or addiction or it can be it could
be drugs it could be because people want
to find something else because P altom
Utley people think we'll you know we're
just here there's got to be some meaning
or purpose or maybe some other dimension
I mean you it's it's like when you get
people who say you know I'm not
religious but I'm spiritual and you know
they're searching maybe they're using
psychedelic drugs to find to enter some
other plane or they're meditating or
whatever and then which which is which
is fine but um to me it's it's very much
a parallel it's like you're trying to
create something new like a new or on an
alternative version which has some of
the ideas and some of the principles but
mmm misses the sort of aspect of a deity
or something super supernatural but um
yeah I don't know I'm like I'm not I'm
not here making an argument for religion
sure I'm just more saying that well it's
interesting because here you're in
America me I think it's a very American
view that that you're laying out there
because that's the view of the founders
right they said these are god-given
rights we didn't give you these rights
but at the same time what did they say
you have freedom of religion and freedom
from religion yeah so it's a really
beautiful thing that these rights came
from something else before us we're not
handing them to you and there's a
there's a real freedom in that yeah
definitely and I another one I mean just
on a more pragmatic level again it's not
an argument in favor of a for religion
but I do also think that there's a
danger if a whole society loses that and
another one does not I think that that
opens them up for the potential takeover
and the lack of lack of a better sense
right I think if you've got if you can
have hundreds of millions of people who
are United around this idea or belief
system and then you've got people who
are kind of splintered off and siloed
and isolated and they don't
have anything that's really they feel
anyway is uniting them as a community or
one not I do think that poses as a
threat to them because there's no
there's there's nothing competing to
protect against that so I think on again
on a wider longer term span I do think
that's something that's a potential risk
some people might say okay well whatever
that doesn't matter but those are my
personal that's my personal thought on
it is something I've thought about is
something I've thought about quite a lot
and again you know having grown up in a
country like Saudi Arabia which is
99.99% Islamic and everybody essentially
believes in God and everybody follows
the same religion and they've got very
strict rules on making sure things stay
that way right there's zero churches
there zero synagogues can only build
mosques and so and you know they're
they're very strict and structured in
the way that they they do certain things
so some people might not like that but
again from their own perspective if I
use them p'tee to kind of put myself in
their shoes it's like okay I get what I
can get what you're doing here and why
you may be doing this so even if people
in the Western world don't like it or
they may think that it's backwards or
that it's it's not correct and whatnot
you can understand I think if you've got
high degree of empathy you can
understand where some of that thinking
sort of comes from yeah yeah so you're
saying that perhaps having a little bit
of a traditional sense and also a little
bit of free thinking might be yeah the
way to do it yeah I think crazy man I
think you can reach out you can reach a
happy happy medium you know you're
always going to have a balance between
Liberty and on the other side let's see
if you give people absolute liberty and
freedom then that has consequences I say
this from someone who's pretty
libertarian it generally thinks people
should be able to do what they want as
long as it's not harming killing or
taking from other people mm-hmm but
need some if you want that to function
you need some kind of fabric over it so
that people do behave in a way that's
not massively destructive to themselves
or to others and then you've got the
opposite where you've got a country like
the one I want I grew up in where it's
super super duper strict you know in
something there's plenty of things that
I think are way too strict in which I
personally don't believe in or subscribe
to but stuff is very ordered and
everyone knows how things kind of work
and there are problems that you get in
the West that you don't really get there
or too far lesser degrees just because
people are you know things and things
are so much more stringent and
structured and repercussions for certain
things are way more serious I mean for
example the death penalty for dealing
drugs which can totally understand
someone thinking that's that's way too
hardcore but you know you look at some
of the problems some of the biggest
problems in the US and the UK are
drug-related yeah or alcohol-related I
think there's a happy medium here I
think exactly this is it I always say to
people happy medium yeah I think there's
a happy medium I don't think you need to
go all the way that way but if you're
gonna go all the way that way in terms
of legality you need something that it's
like okay maybe people should be allowed
to do some of these things they
shouldn't necessarily have a lossing you
can't do that you can't do that you
can't do that punishment punishment
punishment but you also want people to I
don't know like this this is again is
what I think like religion has done in
the past and still it still continues to
so it's like okay it's not illegal
mm-hmm to do all these things you're not
going to get punished but people know
okay well I'm gonna behave in this
certain way because that's what pleases
God and my family and wider society and
whatnot if I don't do these things and
whatnot so I don't know I don't have all
the answers
yeah it's Alliston you don't have all
the answers
that gets forget some of these other
questions my last question because you
are Brent legally I have to ask you
what's gonna happen with Bragg's it oh
gosh I don't know but they need to just
make it happen
really I take it I take an unpopular
view on this in that I've never believed
the dooms the doomsday predictions on
either side I'm not a believer that if
the UK were to stay in the EU that it
would everything would go horribly wrong
I'm also not of the opinion that if the
UK leaves the EU things will go horribly
wrong I think the UK in the long term
Britain will be fine either way now that
I think that the vote has happened and
majority of people voted to leave I
think that that needs to be honored I
think that that needs to happen I don't
know all the details of the best way to
formulate a deal or to just pull out no
deal or anything like that but I think
that now people have voted it's
important that that is upheld I don't
really like this idea that of there
being a vote a democratic vote and then
people start contesting because they
don't like the they don't like the
result if you're looking for more honest
and thoughtful conversations about
politics instead of non-stop yelling
check out our politics playlist and if
you want to watch full interviews on a
variety of topics check out our full
episode playlist all right over here and
to get notified of all future videos be
sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell